[Musique]
le continent compte bien sûr quelques
femmes présidentes à son actif mais
souvent à titre symbolique affoussy
bamba lamine êtes une femme politique
est ce que votre parcours a été semé
d'embûches sur les six que voilà vous
n'êtes la poubelle
avoir les idées quand on regarde les
chiffres sur 255
5 les femmes ferait mieux que les hommes
dans le domaine de l'éveil démocratique
lorsque les femmes sont de plus en plus
prises en compte dans l'échiquier
politique
ça traduit généralement un d'éveil des
consciences un éveil politique bénéficie
à la population d'une manière générale
l'évolution des femmes en politique ça
ne doit pas être qu'une idée ça va elle
aussi un engagement que le président
[Musique]
le résultat inverse peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre
qu'on vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure d'unir nos deux singes
le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous savons
cousin elle remet en maternelle qui
était bretonne me disais si toi tu
descendu sa joie sûrement pas révélé
nous un secret vous en avez mangé du
mamouth je me trouve à fouiller en
sibérie et puis un bon matin dans le
trou que j'avais commencé à creuser je
trouve de lait tout comme ce quelque
chose de bien les grands filaments je
suis étonnée je râle je dirais que ce
sont des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre est une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé il
a toujours existé ou la première grande
manifestation parisienne le 6 février 34
de même pu craindre la disparition de la
toute jeune garde républicaine ou butant
la presse s'était déchaînée sur ce
qu'était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc insu réalité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
un premier cas du nouveau variant
sud-africain détecté en belgique baptisé
au micron il est classé préoccupant par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
commission européenne recommande aux
pays de l'union européenne la suspension
des vols depuis l'afrique australe on en
parle dès le début de ce journal
fin des blocages des ports par les
pêcheurs français après une journée de
mobilisation
ils entendaient obtenir le règlement du
litige de pêche d'après près exit entre
la france et le royaume uni la pêche
n'est pas le seul sujet de tension entre
les deux pays alors qu'une réunion de
crise sur les migrants est prévue
dimanche le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin a annulé sa
participation à réaction à une exigence
du premier ministre britannique boris
johnson qui demande à la france de
reprendre les migrants arrivés en grande
bretagne
[Musique]
et puis il y a un an les paysans bien
lancé un appel inédit aux paysans du
monde pour leur libération comme une
libération entre les géants de
l'agroalimentaire et de la distribution
à l'origine de cette colère une série de
loi mettant en place une réforme
agricole en inde nous reviendrons sur ce
soulèvement à la fin de ce journal
[Musique]
il est 20h bonsoir et bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez sur rt france
après le royaume-uni l'allemagne
l'italie mais aussi la france suspendu
leurs vols en provenance d'afrique
australe en cause ce nouveau variant sud
africain qui inquiète alors que l'europe
fait déjà face à une hausse des cas de
kovy 19 baptisé au micron par l' oms ce
nouveau variant est décrit comme
préoccupant le point avec samira châblis
d1 1 529 une lettre et cinq chiffres qui
provoque une inquiétude mondiale après
la découverte de ce variant du colis de
19 en afrique du sud
signe de la crainte qu'il suscite la
chute enregistrée sur les marchés
boursiers la london stock exchange et le
cac 40 ont ainsi perdu plus de 3 et 4%
ce vendredi
confronté à une cinquième vague
épidémique l'europe redoutent l'arrivée
de ce variant ce qui a conduit certains
pays à prendre des mesures préventives
machine à fric à hunt
ce matin nous avons décidé que l'afrique
du sud et quelques-uns de ses pays
voisins seront déclarées zones à variant
à court terme cela signifie qu'en voyage
vers l'allemagne via une compagnie
aérienne les possibles que pour les ados
à rome notre objectif doit être d'éviter
autant que possible l'introduction de ce
variant
meaux seine et marne trac
c'est la dernière chose dont nous ayons
besoin impérieux de situation actuelle
est qu'un variant supplémentaires
viennent s'ajouter à la vague
l'allemagne donc mais aussi la france
l'italie ou encore singapour et les
philippines
de nombreux pays ont déjà décidé de
suspendre leur liaison avec l'afrique
australe l'un des premiers à avoir
dégainé et le royaume uni les premières
indications montrent que ce variant
pourrait être et plus transmissible que
le variant delta et que les vaccins
actuels pourraient être moins efficace
il pourrait également avoir un impact
sur l'efficacité de l'un d'eux les
principaux traitements le rhône après ve
nous sommes également préoccupés par
l'augmentation des cas dans les pays
d'afrique australe d'autant plus que ces
populations devraient avoir une immunité
naturelle importante en afrique du sud
en particulier on observe une croissance
exponentielle les cas ayant été
multiplié par quatre au cours des deux
dernières semaines en afrique du sud les
professionnels du tourisme s'inquiète eu
de l'impact de ces décisions sur
l'économie les autorités du pays ont
fait part de leur incompréhension
bien que l'afrique du sud respecte le
droit de tous les pays à prendre les
mesures de précaution nécessaires pour
protéger leurs citoyens la décision du
royaume uni d'interdire temporairement
l'entrée des sud africains semblent être
hâtive puisque même le ms n'a pas encore
donné son avis sur les prochaines
mesures
la ministre n'a lendi pandore a déclaré
notre préoccupation immédiate et le
préjudice que cette décision va causer
aux industries du tourisme et aux
entreprises des deux pays l'afrique du
sud va engager le dialogue avec le
gouvernement britannique afin de le
persuader de réexaminer cette décision
de son côté l'organisation mondiale de
la santé est également en alerte et
scrute de près l'évolution de ce variant
ce soir au terme d'une réunion d'urgence
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
classé le nouveau variant sud-africain
préoccupant celui ci est désormais
baptisé au micron en variant qui
existeraient déjà dans d'autres pays
quand en afrique australe c'est ce que
nous explique alan sanou à il est
médecin généraliste à johannesbourg
l'afrique du sud est à sont très bien
organisés au point de vue maladies
infectieuses la feue la voir les clips
tournés johannesburg ils ont été les
premiers à découvrir ce virus se mutant
plutôt doux ont maintenant le virus il
convient de 19,7 se maria est nommé
invariants sud africain
mais c'est parce qu'il a été découvert
le premier en afrique du sud c'est pas
pour cette raison la clé d'origine
sud-africaine
apparemment existerait déjà dans
d'autres pays en afrique australe en
chine en grand et en asie à part moi
même en nouvelle zélande en france le
gouvernement repousse au 31 décembre
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants en
martinique et en guadeloupe obligations
à l'origine d'une véritable crise dans
les deux îles un couvre-feu est
d'ailleurs mise en place en martinique
de 19h à 5h du matin après de violentes
manifestations
plusieurs journalistes ont été visés par
des coups de feu cette nuit des
policiers ont également été blessés
attention aussi en guadeloupe où le
couvre-feu et lui prolongé jusqu'au 28
novembre
pour georges emmanuel germany bâtonnier
de l'ordre des avocats de martinique le
gouvernement ne gère pas la situation de
la bonne manière et n'entend pas la
colère sociale qui gronde parmi les
habitants
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'entend pas
que il n'est pas possible d'appliquer
l'obligation vaccinale et le pass annie
terre de la même façon qu'en france donc
la population réagit les syndicats
essaient avec les élus de trouver les
moyens de rentrer en communication avec
le gouvernement met véritablement en un
gouvernement un peu autiste en tout cas
sourds et aveugles ça c'est sûr et qui
ne répondent aux souffrances sociales à
la vie chez à au problème de l'emploi
des jeunes que par l'envoi de forces
armées de forces militaires et ceux qui
ne fait que rajouter en plus à
l'intention et aux violences
situation sanitaire en espagne où le
gouvernement suspende le pass sanitaire
en catalogne en cause une saturation des
sites internet plus de précisions à
barcelone avec clémentine oran le site
des services de santé saturé et le past
and i ter annulés c'est la situation
assez inédite que vit la catalogne alors
vu des chiffres alarmants de covin 19
dans la région le gouvernement catalan
avait décidé ce jeudi d'élargir la mise
en place du pass sanitaires pour entrer
dans les restaurants mais également dans
les salles de sport et pour les visites
dans les hôpitaux et les maisons de
retraite alors cet élargissement devait
être mise en place dès le lendemain le
vendredi ce qui a provoqué la
stupéfaction du secteur de la
restauration
la plupart des restaurateurs se disait
être pris de court mais dans la journée
de vendredi le gouvernement après la
décision de reporter la mise en place du
pass au lundi suivant et la raison c'est
que le site des services de santé a été
pris d'assaut il ya tout simplement
cessé de fonctionner pour les catalans
elle était donc impossible de
télécharger le pass sanitaire mais
également impossible de prendre un
rendez vous chez le médecin ou encore de
consulter les résultats d'une analyse à
15 heures ce sont pas moins de 500 mille
personnes qui étaient connectés en
attente sur le site il faut rappeler que
le pass and i ter était déjà exigé dans
certains cas en catalogne mais il était
loin d'être généralisée on le demande et
jusqu'à jeudi seulement pour rentrer
dans la discothèque dans les bar dansant
à l'entrée des concerts ou encore pour
les célébrations mais la situation
sanitaire s'est brusquement dégradé en
catalogne comme dans le reste de
l'europe ces deux dernières semaines les
hospitalisations pour kobe 19 ont
augmenté de 60%
les tensions s'accumulent entre la
france et le royaume uni les pêcheurs
européens peuvent continuer à travailler
dans les eaux britanniques mais à
condition de pouvoir prouver qu'ils y
pêchait bien auparavant désaccord sur la
nature et l'ampleur des justificatifs à
fournir conséquence la france n'a pas
les licences qu'elle demande alors les
pêcheurs français ont décidé de passer à
l'action depuis ce matin ils ont bloqué
pendant une heure le port de saint malo
puis celui de calais et de ouistreham le
opérations de blocage également à
l'entrée dû tunnel sous la manche tout à
l'heure des blocages qui ont finalement
pris fin et coûté un manifestant de cali
il ya deux messages d'une que le
gouvernement britannique se bouge un peu
pour faire avancer cette histoire de
licence et de deux que la commission
prenne devrait véritablement conscience
de ce qui se passe là apparemment elle
en a pris conscience hier en imposant
une ultimate sommes au 10 décembre pour
que cette histoire de licence soit le
président emmanuel macron à privilégier
la négociation
on aurait préféré les mesures de
rétorsion mais je pense que ça doit pas
être quelque chose de simple à mettre en
place et je pense que c'est surtout le
rôle de la commission européenne
d'imposer des mesures de rétorsion et
non la france parce que c'est la france
qui va encore se faire passer pour le
mauvais élève donc voilà les activer oui
je serai premier à le vouloir mais il
faut comprendre que c'est pas si simple
que ça
crispation également entre paris et
londres autour de la crise migratoire
plus précisément des exilés qui
traversent la manche depuis la france
pour rejoindre la grande bretagne
mercredi au moins 27 d'entre eux sont
morts dans la manche un drame qui n'a
fait que raviver les tensions entre les
deux pays boris johnson a adressé une
lettre à emmanuel macron une lettre
d'exigence qu'il assume et qui ne plaît
pas du tout à paris conséquence elles
des invits londres de la réunion de
crise sur les migrants prévu ce dimanche
bilal bouazzouni
c'est une décision qui ne va pas
arranger les relations déjà tendues
entre la france et le royaume uni ces
dernières semaines alors qu'une réunion
sur les migrants à laquelle devaient
participer les ministres chargés de
l'immigration français belges allemands
néerlandais britanniques et la
commission européenne était prévue ce
dimanche à calais le ministre de
l'intérieur français gérald darmanin a
décidé d'annuler la venue de son
homologue britannique priti patel
nous considérons la lettre publique du
premier ministre britannique comme
inadmissible et contraire à nos
discussions entre homologues par
conséquent priti patel n'est plus convié
dimanche à la réunion interministérielle
qui est maintenue au format france
belgique pays-bas allemagne et
commission européenne la raison de cette
annulation se trouve dans la lettre
adressée par le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson à emmanuel
macron hier soir et les tweets qui ont
suivi dans lesquelles il donne ses
recommandations à la france pour lutter
contre l'immigration illégale
ce soir j'ai écrit au président macron
pour lui proposer d'aller plus loin et
plus vite pour empêcher les traversées
de la manche et éviter une répétition de
la tragédie épouvantable d'hier qui a
coûté la vie à au moins 27 personnes
j'ai proposé de travailler sur un accord
de retour bilatérales avec la france
parallèlement à des pourparlers pour
établir un accord de retour entre le
royaume uni ait lieu un accord avec la
france pour reprendre les migrants qui
traversent la manche par cette route
dangereuse aurait un impact immédiat et
important mais ce qui a provoqué la
colère du gouvernement français c'est
que le premier ministre britannique a
rendu publique cette lettre et la
diffuser sur son compte twitter je suis
surpris des méthodes quand elles ne sont
pas sérieuses on ne communique pas d'un
dirigeant l'autre sur ces questions-là
par twitté par lettre qu'on rend public
nous ne sommes pas des lanceurs d'alert
allons allons donc les ministres vont
travailler sérieusement pour régler une
question sérieuse avec des gens sérieux
c'est pour cela que dès dimanche le
ministre darmana réunira ses homologues
de l'union européenne et la commission
pour travailler sur ce sujet et ensuite
nous verrons avec les britanniques
comment agir efficacement s'il décide
d'être sérieux après l annonce du
gouvernement français londres a demandé
à paris de rétablir l'invitation de la
ministre britannique alors que 27
migrants ont perdu la vie mercredi la
crise diplomatique entre la france et le
royaume uni n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
pour jérémy stubb président de
l'association conservateurs britanniques
à paris les tensions entre paris et
londres sont aussi d'ordre personnel
il y a non seulement plusieurs sujets de
différends entre la france et le royaume
uni il ya aussi je pense indifférent un
peu personnel entre les deux chefs
le chef d'état français et le chef du
gouvernement britannique
alors on est on en est à des
démonstrations de déplaisir des uns
envers les autres
âmes et malheureusement les trois
affaires le protocole de l'irlande du
nord la pêche et les migrants sont
imbriquées les unes dans les autres
alors c'est pour ça que c'est devenu
très très très complexe
crise migratoire également méditerranée
avec cette nouvelle opération de
sauvetage au large des côtes tunisiennes
la marine nationale et les garde côtes
ont secouru in extremis près de 500
migrants qui tentaient de rejoindre
l'europe avant le naufrage de leur
embarcation le point sur cette situation
on ira thouars avec notre correspondant
à tunis pacem chez lui
ils avaient l'espoir de rejoindre
l'europe par la mer mais le rêve a très
vite tourné au cauchemar partis de libye
près de 500 migrants de différentes
nationalités ont été secourus ce matin à
l'eau par les unités de la marine
tunisienne après le naufrage de leur
embarcation au large de la ville de sfax
dans le nord-est du pays une patrouille
de haute mer appuyés par des unités de
la marine et des garde-côtes ont secouru
vendredi à l'aube 487 migrants
clandestins de différentes nationalités
arabes asiatiques et africaines
l'embarcation était partie des côtes
libye et se diriger vers l'espace
européen parmi ces migrants des
égyptiens des bengals est des syriens
des soudanais ou encore des marocains
tous déterminés à fuir leur pays au
péril de leur vie le ministère tunisien
de la défense a déclaré que 13 femmes
n'est pas moins de 93 enfants figuraient
parmi la liste des naufragés hier les
autorités tunisiennes avaient déjà fait
état de neuf opérations de sauvetage
depuis le début de la semaine et ont
permis de sauver quelques 200 personnes
en octobre quatre tunisiens avaient
perdu la vie en mer en tentant de
rejoindre l'île italienne de lampedusa
est distante de seulement 140 km des
côtes tunisiennes depuis la chute de
kadhafi en 2011 la libye pourtant plongé
dans le chaos politique est devenue une
des principales plaques tournantes de
l'immigration clandestine à destination
de l'europe pour des milliers de
migrants selon l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations le
nombre de migrants morts en mer a
quasiment doublé en un an passant de 5
113 à plus de 1100 46 au premier
semestre 2008 et un
autre titre de ce journal c'est un an de
contestation paysanne en inde le 26
novembre 2001 marquait le début d'un
soulèvement d'une ampleur inédite dans
le pays une colère populaire générés par
l'adoption d'une réforme agricole très
controversé après plusieurs mois de
confrontation l'exécutif indien a
annoncé la mort gassion de ces lois la
semaine dernière aujourd'hui des
milliers d'agriculteurs se rendre aux
portes de la capitale pour marquer ce
première anniversaire du soulèvement
retour sur une année une année de bras
de fer avec hélène masquelier
[Applaudissements]
26 novembre 2020
des dizaines de milliers de paysans
marche vers la capitale principalement
originaire du pendjab et de l'uttar
pradesh
ils sont venus à siéger new delhi la
raison de leur colère trois lois
adoptées par le gouvernement un mois
plus tôt pour mettre en place une
réforme agricole visant à libéraliser le
secteur les petits paysans craignent de
se retrouver à la merci de grands
groupes et de voir leurs prix chuter
[Musique]
nous allons souffrir d' énormes pertes à
cause des lois de modifs
ils essayent de privatiser notaire en
premier il met fin à tous les marchés
qui sont connectés aux fermiers les
fermiers vont souffrir
[Musique]
le mouvement social prend une ampleur
inédite 250 millions de travailleurs se
mettent en grève
tous les secteurs sont touchés
le pays se retrouve à l'arrêt pendant ce
temps les agriculteurs et riche de petit
village à la périphérie de la capitale
et commence à s'organiser le bras de fer
ne fait que commencer
avec la répression violente des
manifestations la colère s'intensifie
des affrontements cause la mort de plus
de 700 paysans le dialogue est rompu
jusqu'à la semaine dernière volte-face
du gouvernement qui décide de retirer sa
réforme
mais
a mis aujourd'hui je demande aux
agriculteurs qui protestent en ce jour
pieux de l'anniversaire de naissance de
guru nanak s'il vous plaît retournez
chez vous dans vos fermés dans vos
familles
prenons un nouveau départ
aie aie aie
un revirement qui survient quelques mois
seulement avant des élections régionales
clés notamment au pendjab qui regroupe
les plus grandes exploitations agricoles
du pays
mais à la frontière de new delhi dans
les campements d'agriculteurs la
méfiance restera de mise tant que
l'abrogation de la réforme n'aura pas
été actée par le parlement
[Musique]
vladimir poutine accueillait aujourd'hui
une rencontre tripartite avec le premier
ministre arménien nikol pashinian et le
président azerbaïdjanais ilham aliyev
une rencontre qui arrive un peu plus
d'un an après le conflit dans le
haut-karabagh la rencontre a duré trois
heures elle a été qualifiée de positive
par les trois leaders ont fait le point
avec notre correspondante à moscou
verhaeghe hoffman
il est important qu'il ya un intérêt des
deux côté azéri et arménien pour la
normalisation des relations a déclaré
vladimir poutine lors d'une réunion
trilatérale à sotchi avec le président
azéri ilham aliev et le premier ministre
arménien nicolas pas génial pour le
président russie beaucoup de choses ont
été mises en oeuvre depuis le conflit
armé en 2020 au haut karabagh le but de
ces efforts des créer les conditions
d'un renouveau dans la région afin que
les populations s'y sentent en sécurité
écouter
en effet pas mal de choses ont été
faites pendant ce temps malheureusement
toutes les questions n'ont pas encore
été réglés je sais qu'il ya eu des
incidents à la frontière des incidents
tragiques ou périssent et sont blessés
des gens des deux parties
ce sont des choses qui exige une
attention particulière de notre part
c'est pour cela entre autres que nous
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
pour prévenir des incidents de ce type
dans l'avenir n'est en général pas mal
de choses ont été faites en l'espace
d'un an première chose il n'y a pas
d'hostilité de grande envergure ce qui
est déjà une bonne chose pendant ce
temps avec une assistante de notre part
un important travail a été accompli pour
faire venir les réfugiés 53000 sont
revenus dans leur lieu de résidence
permanente
quant au président azéri ilham aliev il
s'est dit prêt à entamer le processus de
démarcation des frontières entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan et a remercié
moscou pour l'envoi et le rôle joué par
les casques bleus russes dans la région
écoutez
l'azerbaïdjan apprécié votre
participation personnelle en ce qui
concerne le règlement des relations
entre l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie et bien
sûr votre participation active à
l'élaboration du texte de la déclaration
l'année dernière comme vous l'avez noté
nous nous sommes rencontrés dans ce
format en début d'année et maintenant
nous nous rencontrons à la fin de
l'année pour peut faire le bilan et bien
sûr en général la situation dans la zone
de responsabilité des forces de maintien
de la paix russes est stable
il n'y a eu aucun incident grave aucune
provocation délibérée les cas isolé
observés étaient de nature non
systémiques par conséquent je tiens à
remercier le contingent russe de
maintien de la paix pour le service
qu'ils effectuent ils assurent la
sécurité dans une région qui est dans un
état de conflits gelés depuis de
nombreuses années et l'année dernière
elle était dans un état de guerre de
grande ampleur
le premier ministre arménien nicole
petignat n'a quant à lui pointé du doigt
elle les problèmes qui demeurent dans la
région en ce qui concerne les otages et
les prisonniers de guerre écouter
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la
formulation du président azerbaïdjanais
notamment sur le fait que toutes les
dispositions à part celle de la levée du
blocus sur des communications ont été
mises en oeuvre vous savez que nous en
avons maintes fois discuté avec vous
lors de nos réunions personnel et par
téléphone notamment concernant le
problème actuel des otages et d'autres
personnes détenus des prisonniers de
guerre
et
est
chose qu'un match
c'est une question humanitaire très
importante mais je veux dire qu'à mon
avis nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pas
seulement pour présenter ces problèmes
et pour parler des solutions aux
problèmes qui existent moi aussi j'ai
déclaré plusieurs fois que l'arménie
était prête à commencer le processus de
la démarcation et de la délimitation des
frontières
c'est rencontre trilatérale et russie
arménie azerbaïdjan est consécutive aux
affrontements entre les deux pays du
caucase à la mi-novembre en cause encore
et toujours le contrôle de la région
montagneuse du nagorno karabagh qui se
disputent erevan et beaucoup depuis des
décennies et passe maintenant à notre
rubrique art et sur le web une sélection
d'articles à retrouver sur le site
internet arte france pointe est né
le sort de julian assange inquiète à
l'onu le rapporteur général sur la
torture dit craindre une issue
défavorable pour le lanceur d' alerte il
regrette que le traitement de cette
affaire ne se focalise que sur les
questions de détention du journaliste et
non sur le fond à savoir la persécution
d'un homme qui dit innocent
en biélorussie le président s'est
adressé aux migrants à la frontière
polonaise il a déclaré qu'il ne
retiendrait pas de force ceux qui
souhaitent gagner l'union européenne
alexandre loukachenko a appelé
l'allemagne à accueillir ces migrants au
risque d'aggraver les tensions
et puis à la justice française ouvre une
enquête préliminaire contre nicolas
hulot l'ancien ministre est accusé de
viol les témoignages de ses présumées
victimes ont été rendus publics dans un
reportage diffusé sur france télévisions
l'enquète doit permettre de déterminer
si les faits dénoncés caractérise une
infraction pénale au moins six femmes
accusent l'ex animateur d'agression
sexuelle
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
se poursuit depuis hier autour des
enquêteurs belges d'être entendu ils
doivent notamment évoquer le séjour en
syrie du frère de salars abdeslam les
précisions de notre reporter katia pique
nique devant le palais de justice
une journée au goût amer aujourd'hui au
procès des attentats avec ce qui
apparaît comme des insuffisances du côté
de l'anc est belge il faut savoir que
salah abdeslam a refusé de comparaître à
l'audience aujourd'hui ainsi que quatre
autres accusés hier ils étaient quatre
ans tout a boycotté l'audience la raison
depuis hier ce sont les enquêteurs
belges qui s'exprime en visioconférence
et le procureur fédéral de belgique a
instamment demandé que l'anonymat des
enquêteurs soit préservée et les accusés
manifestent leur mécontentement à ce
sujet mais peu importe les audiences ont
repris il faut dire qu'il existe une
polémique concernant l' enquête belge
déjà dénoncée par quelques médias
français en septembre dernier qui avait
dénoncé des failles dans la surveillance
des frères abdeslam alors des échanges
tendus ont eu lieu hier et aujourd'hui
car à des avocats de parties civiles ont
voulu comprendre pourquoi certains
accusés dans le viseur des eaux rites et
belges ont pu échapper à leur vigilance
ou s'enfuir aujourd'hui la cour s'est
penchée sur le cas de brahim abdeslam le
frère de saleh abdeslam après avoir tiré
sur les terrasses le 13 novembre il
s'est fait sauter dans un bar parisien
en janvier on a appris en janvier 2015
évidemment on a appris que brahim
abdeslam était signalé comme allant en
syrie qu'il s'intéressait au terrorisme
le barde brahim abdeslam été identifié
comme un lieu de radicalisation alors
pourquoi l'at-on aussi peu suivi ont
demandé les avocats des parties civiles
l'enquêteur s'est défendu expliquant que
brave abdeslam était fichiers dans la
liste des personnes à contrôler
discrètement n'étaient pas fichés du
côté terrorisme et le pire est révélée
en février 2015 brahim abdeslem est
arrêté pour une chose anodine on
retrouve sur lui un tract pour autoriser
le jihad pour les mineurs dont les
parents ne sont pas d'accord avec un tel
engagement les policiers belle
saisissent alors son téléphone mais on
ne l'analyse pas vraiment malgré toutes
ces alertes encore une faille détectée
par l'avocat des parties civiles maître
gérard chemla une conversation cruciale
avec about sur le projet d'attentât
aurait pu être retrouvé déchire ses
coups forts et prend leur un maximum de
porcs et vient rejoindre l'armée dallas
c'est l'objet de cette conversation donc
un témoignage tendu aujourd'hui karl
enquêteurs belges n'a pas offert
d'explication m chemla parler d'un échec
majeur des services de surveillance
belge voilà pour cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
récemment le gouvernement français a
violemment réagi à l'annoncé d'un
mémorandum d'intention passé entre
wagner et le gouvernement malien la
france a été progressivement perçue est
considérée comme une armée d'occupation
qui protégeait les régimes en place au
mali mais aussi au tchad la france ne se
retire pas ni du mali du sahel s'agit
bien d'une transformation une
réorganisation ce ne sont plus les
militaires français forcément qu'ils
sont aux premières lignes ce sont les
militaires maliens au regard de la
situation actuelle il est clair